- Hey Kari!
We're doing it.
How ya doing?
- Hey Keith.
- I was overhearing a conversation about
a bunch of joints at the inauguration.
You're in charge of research at BuzzFeed.
I figure if anybody knows
it's true or not it's you.
(dramatic music)
Is there gonna be a bunch of weed at D.C.
(Kari and Keith laughing)
when he's getting inaugurated?
That sounds amazing.
- There's a lot of stuff going
on with the inauguration.
- I admit okay that's true, I imagine.
- Yeah, I feel like the most
important place to start
is with Nickelback.
♫ Look at this photograph
("Photograph" by Nickelback)
- Hold on, what does
Nickelback have anything
to do with the inauguration?
- So there was this tweet going around.
People were just like
re-posting this image
on Facebook and Twitter.
- Yes.
Donald Trump says we did it!
We secured Nickelback
for the inauguration.
Very pleased, a great American band.
♫ Hey girl
- It sounds like him, right?
- That's Trump.
That is how Trump tweets.
It's his handle.
It's verified.
We've got a timestamp.
It's all good.
So they're playing at the inauguration?
- They're actually not.
It's fake.
- Oh no!
He lost them.
- No it's fake.
- It's fake.
- No, it's not like they
backed out at the last minute.
- How can it be fake?
It's very Trumpy.
It's a tweet.
- So the thing is this is just an image.
It's not a link.
There's like no proof.
You can't click through
and check it.
- I can't trust pictures
on the internet?
- No.
Cause you can fake them.
- I know mine are real.
I mean, I do filter them.
- So there you go.
- Yeah I guess so.
- So here's what he actually
tweeted at that same time.
- "We did it!
"Thank you to all my great supporters,
"we just officially won the election
"despite all of the distorted
and inaccurate media."
- So look, the time stamp and
the date are the exact same.
- Oh.
So he didn't get Nickelback?
- No.
- Well was it because
Nickelback was too busy?
- Let's look at their tour schedule.
- Ooh.
They only have three shows in 2017.
- Maybe they just haven't booked them yet.
- I just really wish they
were playing the inauguration.
♫ Look at this photograph
Okay so what else you got?
- So after Meryl Streep's
Golden Globes speech
the New York Times called him
to get his thoughts on it and
- Why not?
- [Kari] Well that's what you do.
- I mean she calls him out.
- What's a better source than
going directly to the source?
- Call him on the Trump phone.
- But then he ended up saying this.
- "We are goint to have an unbelievable,
"perhaps record-setting
turnout for the inauguration,
"and there will be plenty of
movie and entertainment stars.
"All the dress shops are
sold out in Washington.
"It's hard to find a great
dress for the inauguration."
Poor Trump.
He wants a dress.
He can't even get his own dress?
- Yeah.
- Well that's terrible.
- I know.
- They're all sold out.
- I mean the thing is The New York Times
didn't fact check what he said.
- Why not?
- We could fact check what he says.
- Let's fact check it.
Right now?
- Yeah we could call a dress shop.
(upbeat music)
(ringing)
- [Woman on Phone] Ella-Rue,
how may I help you?
- Hi, I'm Keith,
I was wondering if y'all have any dresses.
- [Ella-Rue] We do.
What type of event are you shopping for?
- You know what, I'm shopping
for the inauguration.
I need several dresses.
- [Ella- Rue] Which kind?
Like, what style?
- Kari, help me out here.
- Hey no.
Listen.
I mean the style doesn't really matter.
I think we're more
wondering how many dresses
you have to choose from.
- Like do you have a lot of dresses?
- [Ella-Rue] We have plenty
for you all to look at.
Let us know when you want to come in.
- I'm just gonna be honest.
I'm probably not coming.
- [Ella-Rue] Alright, thank you.
- Alright, bye.
(upbeat music)
Trump was wrong.
- He said something that wasn't true.
So there's fake news.
There's real news that's fake.
- Well this was real news.
But it was just like, he lied.
- Yeah.
- Okay so Nickelback's not playing.
There are plenty of dresses
for Trump to choose from.
What about the weed?
Tell me about the weed.
Cause now I'm assuming that
the weed can't be real either.
All these stories seem fake.
- So the good news is the weed is real.
- We're doing it?
They're giving out weed?
- It's real.
You can get some weed if
you go to the inauguration.
- How many weeds can I have?
- So CNN it turns out
if you read this story.
The people passing out the weed
are from an organization
called DCMJ, which helped pass
- Dis cannibis my jam.
- That's probably what it stands for.
Sure.
- What is it actually?
- It's D.C. Marijuana.
- Oh okay.
D.C. Mary Jane I guess.
- [Kari] Yeah.
- So are they going to give
these out to only chill people?
Or they gonna choose,
like, the old angry people
to say, like, chill out?
Like who's getting the weed?
- It sounds like anyone.
They are passing out 4,200
joints at the inauguration.
- If Trump has not said
he'll legalize weed
throughout the country in the first
four minutes and twenty
seconds of his speech
then everyone should light
their joints at the same time.
- Sounds like a bunch of potheads to me.
So this is true.
There really will be
weed at the inauguration.
- Well that's good news.
- Yeah.
- You know, cause there's
going to be all these people
upset about not having dresses,
and upset that Nickelback's not there,
and they're gonna need
something to chill out with,
and at least they're gonna have
4,200 joints to choose from.
- It's true.
I think you'll probably just get one.
I don't know if you get to
choose your pick between 4,200.
- Pick between, okay.
- Yeah.
And do you think Trump
will be offered any weed?
He knows all about weed.
He talks about weed with the best weeds.
- I think we might need
to fact check that.